and welcome to hannity and we start with
the fox news alert breaking tonight we
have all three major broadcast networks
fake news cnn msdnc all happily
broadcasting well the dulles the most
boring there's absolutely nothing
nothing new multi-hour democratic
fundraiser masquerading as a january 6
hearing and by the sounds of it they're
going to do hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours of this
produced by a former abc executive a
hundred percent hollywood production
with all the creative license that would
go along with that but make no mistake
tonight's so-called hearing is not in
good faith it is not an honest probe
into the security breakdown on that
fateful day and we will prove that to
you tonight instead it is a made for tv
smear campaign against president trump
featuring sliced and diced video that
fits their predetermined political
narrative from the very beginning
accompanied by the biggest trump haters
on capitol hill
every single person on this committee is
on record hating president trump and
they all voted to impeach him now people
who support donald trump were not
allowed to participate on this
illegitimate hyper partisan committee
and sadly those running this circus are
not interested in what went wrong
they're not interested in what actually
happened they are purposely omitting
what is critical information we will
tell you about tonight and we will show
you tonight that will reveal where
massive security failures did occur and
beyond that show you the people
that are responsible for all of those
security failures and how the committee
is protecting all of them from being
exposed tonight we will name names we
will also show you how president trump
our defense department the capitol
police offered every warning and
opportunity to protect the capital and
they were rejected every single time now
we must learn the truth so something
like this can never happen again i spoke
out about it in real time on my radio
show and on january 6 on this program
that night now sadly this committee
prefers politics over safety on this
program we believe that improving
security at the capitol protecting all
elected officials is of the utmost
importance rather than a vengeful smear
campaign like we see unfolding so unlike
this committee and their cheerleaders in
the media mob we will actually be
telling you the truth now tonight thanks
to the very diligent reporting from john
solomon uh we now have troves of newly
unearthed documents and our own sources
and we have now been able to put
together a critical timeline that i
promise you're not going to see anywhere
else now this is the official timeline
of the capitol police as obtained by
investigative reporter john solomon he
will join us in a little bit and we
begin on january 2nd 2021 we now know
today definitively that on january 2nd
four days before the sixth that trump's
department of defense and one of his
officials from the trump administration
in fact reached out to the capitol
police department asking the deputy
chief if they were planning on calling
up the national guard to help protect
the capital ahead of the massive rally
that was planned on january 6th now the
next day on january third after
consulting with the capitol police chief
deputy chief sean gallagher told the
department of defense that a request for
national guard was not forthcoming
however shortly thereafter they got new
and darker security assessments that
were issued to the house and senate
sergeants at arms and they discovered
that in fact radical groups were
planning violence now according to the
assessment it said quote due to these
tense the tense political environment
following the 2020 election the threat
of disruptive actions or violence cannot
be ruled out then it continued quote the
sense of desperation and disappointment
may lead to more of an incentive to
become violent now one day later then on
january 4th the capital police chief
steve sun he rightly based on the new
intelligence changed his mind and began
the process of now seeking permission
from the office of nancy pelosi and
chuck schumer to in fact deploy the
national guard using that intelligence
now the house and the senate
sergeant-at-arms they denied this
request why weren't they called before
this hearing anyway still president
trump and top dod officials they forged
ahead with plans to make a massive
amount of national guard troops
available
you might remember
the previous summer this is coming off
the summer of 574
official riots in this country where
dozens of americans were killed where
thousands of police were injured where
there was billions of dollars in
property damage so they rightly wanted
to prepare then on january 4th the
meeting took place in the oval office it
featured president trump his chief of
staff mark meadows acting defense
secretary chris miller the department of
defense chief of staff cash patel who
will also join us tonight and the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
mark milley president trump in that
meeting requested that up to 20 000
national guard troops be made available
for security at the capitol for january
6 as the law requires him to authorize
now the washington post they lied and
claimed that we may must have made this
up they gave out four pinocchios and as
per usual the washington post is either
dishonest or lazy or both they didn't
talk to the people that were actually in
the meeting we did on this program for
the officials four out of the five
present in the oval office have on this
program corroborated our reporting take
a look for yourself did you authorize
calling up the guard and then it became
as the chain of command went to nancy
pelosi and to the mayor of d.c muriel
bowser did you as required by law
authorize that
100 percent
and attested to by many people and they
turned it down
nancy pelosi turned it down mayor
bowser's written refusal the
communications between the leader of the
capitol police and their chain of
command to the dod refusing our request
to allow national guard's men and women
to stage on january 4 and 5 before
january 6. did you both ask for the
national guard to be called up
without a doubt shawn we've made that
very clear not just once but on numerous
occasions we wanted to make sure that
there was plenty of national guard on
the ready
in case there was some kind of violence
i had a meeting with president trump on
the third of january concerning some
international threats and at the very
end he asked if there were any requests
for national guard support what was the
president's response to you
with regard to the request made by mayor
bowser
fill it and do whatever was necessary to
protect the
demonstrators
now in addition to what you just heard
there was one other person in the room
and that is the chairman of the joint
chiefs general milley now this week
people close to him have confirmed
directly to me
that the general absolutely recalls
conversations with president trump about
security prior to january 6. now we're
more than an hour into what this
capital show tonight this so-called
hearing apparently there's going to be
what planned hearings in perpetuity by
the sounds of it and this critical
information this critical meeting has
not been mentioned one time not one time
why
because it doesn't fit sadly their
predetermined political outcome which we
all know is to smear once again donald
trump it's kind of hard to say to
somebody
uh that somebody wanted a riot and
instigated a riot when that same person
uh authorized up to 20 000 troops to
protect that very capital where the
so-called riot uh is going to take place
now keep in mind according to defense
experts the capital would not have been
breached with thousands of national
guard soldiers providing the security
let me say it another way
had they actually listened to president
trump had they listened to the experts
at the department of defense january 6
never would have happened they didn't
listen they were deaf they cared not to
protect the capital they knew they had
574 riots the summer before they knew
tensions in the country were high and
they didn't do their duty they were
begged repeatedly to take the guard and
they wouldn't do it now while the
president can make national guard troops
available it is important to note well
then it becomes the responsibility of
speaker pelosi she's in charge of
security at the capitol and also d.c
mayor bowser she has the jurisdiction
they both have the authority at that
point once the president authorizes the
troops to be called up they're the ones
that have to deploy the troops to the
capital and surrounding areas so the
question that they're not asking that
they should be asking
why didn't pelosi why didn't bowser why
didn't schumer why didn't the
sergeant-at-arms call up the guard why
didn't bowser call up the guard why
didn't schumer say you know what
we should listen to the experts why
didn't the sergeant-at-arms in the house
and senate listened to the capitol
police chief when he was begging them
you know why did they deny the capitol
police chief the troops he said he
needed now if this committee cared at
all about the truth if they cared at all
about preventing something like this
which we should all agree on from ever
happening again they would be demanding
answers from pelosi and schumer and
bowser and both the sergeant of arms at
the in the house and in the senate and
the capitol police chief and the deputy
police chief and everyone else that
would be responsible for securing the
capital why didn't this committee
subpoena all of these people demand all
of their text messages all of their
emails and depose all of them now even
the vengeful and very trump obsessed liz
cheney she actually admitted tonight i
couldn't believe my ears that the
violence on january 6 was not
spontaneous she said it it was not the
result of the president's speech instead
she points out it was pre-planned now as
you watch this ask yourself well if you
knew ahead of time that people were
planning violence why didn't everybody
that that knew this why did they if you
know knew about this why didn't you call
in the guard take a look
the attack on our capital was not a
spontaneous riot
intelligence available before january 6
identified plans to quote invade the
capital
occupy the capital and take other steps
to halt congress's count of electoral
votes that day
okay so now we all they all knew the
violence was pre-planned now that brings
us to january 5th 2021 that evening we
now know that the fbi shared intel with
the capitol police revealing that some
january 6 attendees were plotting an
attempt to violently storm the capital
that's the day before quote an online
thread
discussed specific calls for violence to
include uh stating to be ready to be to
fight congress needs to hear glass
breaking doors being kicked in they
intercepted intel
goes on to say quote get violent stop
calling this a march or rally or a
protest go there ready for war they knew
this on the fifth and according to this
document on your screen the capitol
police emailed the senate sergeant at
arms warning about this group that is
quote promoting the photos of the
capitol tunnel system online and stating
their goal of finding democratic members
early to block them from even entering
the capital now the same email revealed
that rioters were planning to create a
perimeter around the capitol despite all
of that intelligence on january 5th d.c
mayor muriel bowser wrote a letter that
day to the dod
explicitly
asking them not to deploy national guard
troops to the capitol on january 6. why
would she ever make that decision again
why didn't they lift a finger with all
the intelligence they had ahead of time
to protect the capital to protect every
elected official is anyone on this
committee are they ever going to ask
that question of mayor bowser are they
ever going to bring in nancy pelosi and
ask her why she didn't call up the guard
they don't seem to care
apparently because those people have not
been interviewed according to all the
reports i'm reading they only seem to
care about one thing and this is sad
because that house is our house that's
the people's house that's your house and
we need to protect our institutions i
don't care if you're a republican or
democrat and i said it on the sixth
we've got to protect our elected
officials it's that simple and it seems
they only care about smearing trump
exciting their base may be raising money
off all this which now brings us to
january 6th now that morning during his
speech president trump remember he said
these words and they have yet to bring
him up what a shock he said many of you
now will
peacefully and patriotically march to
the capitol so your voices may be heard
and call for violence kind of just the
opposite of what chuck schumer said on
the steps of the u.s supreme court when
he threatened justices and we all know
what happened yesterday
anyway here's the president on january
6. take a look
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
okay unfortunately when the january 6
committee features the eclipse from
trump i'll bet any amount of money
they're going to slice and dice and edit
around that part where he says many of
you will now peacefully patriotically
march to the capitol so your voices will
be heard hmm i wonder why now in the
hours that followed capitol police they
were ill-prepared they were outmanned
and according to the department's after
action report anti-riot squads did not
respond in a timely manner many of their
radios were not working and much of
their riot gear was locked in a bus and
they couldn't find the key now
ultimately the capitol police chief
requested the national guard
and and asked for help six different
times and it wasn't until way late in
the afternoon that pelosi finally said
okay
by that point it was too late the
capital had been breached and ever since
democrats have used this awful day as a
political weapon they don't actually
care about riots or improving safety and
security it's all political remember
this right now there's no congressional
committee ask yourself why don't we have
a committee looking into the 574 riots
that took place in the summer of 2020
dozens of dead americans
thousands of injured police officers
billions in property damage where's that
congressional committee on the federal
courthouse in portland remember night
after night lit on fire for week after
week by far left protesters what no
hearings on that those lives don't
matter that property damage doesn't
matter those police don't matter so here
we are suffering through yet another
anti-trump smear that will accomplish
absolutely nothing hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else